où
alcoolique le mot a été employé pour la
première fois dans les années 1850 par
un médecin suédois
il a fallu attendre un siècle plus d'un
siècle 1978 exactement pour que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé oms
reconnaissent que la maladie alcoolique
et que l'alcoolisme était une maladie
est pas un vice et que l'alcoolique
était un malade et pas un taré c'est une
maladie à part
l'alcoolisme un petit peu particulière
le terme même d'ailleurs d'alcoolique et
des étangs bécu c'est à la fois un
symptôme est aussi une insulte s'est
passé ça vous viendrez à l'esprit
d'insulter quelqu'un alzheimer cardiaque
n'a pas tu n'en ça marche pas trop bien
moi j'ai pas trop bien alcoolo absolue
propres aux alcooliques ça marche
peut-être trouvé ça c'est une insulte
alcoolique non pour être honnête je n'ai
jamais vraiment entendu
ce mot là j'avais une famille deux
enfants
une amoureuse j'avais un métier fabuleux
gratifiant formidable les gens même
l'envié parfois pour ce que je faisais
j'étais une eu une boule dans des cités
jamais à ma place toujours nulle part à
côté en décalage je buvais de plus en
plus et de plus en plus souvent l'alcool
l'alcool me faisait du bien
il me permettait d'être à l'aise
c'était un basque j'étais un imposteur
et pour supporter ça l'alcool très
efficace alors bien sûr je savais que
j'avais comme on dit un problème avec
l'alcool
oui mais c'est juste un petit problème
ça va pas durer longtemps c'est vrai
qu'en ce moment je suis pas trop la
patate j'ai un peu le moral dans les
chaussettes us et le bluetooth à c'est
un peu compliqué non non mais je suis
certainement pas quoi un an non
alcoolique un alcoolique alcoolique non
pas alcoolique pas alcoolique non votre
chien coliques printemps 2008 par des
cinq heures du matin je me réveille j'ai
mal partout la tête le tour de froid
je ne sais pas où je suis comment je
suis arrivé là un hall d'immeuble
les bruits de la rue l'alcool a effacé
mes souvenirs me sont moches salle
devrait rentrer quelques semaines plus
tard ils recommencent allonger cette
fois en vrac sur le palier de
l'appartement que j'occupe avec mon
amoureuse
sur le paillasson
elle me réveille quand elle ouvre la
porte elle doit mangeant b pour sortir
je ne supporterais plus jamais un seul
instant son regard sur elle je n'ose pas
me regarder dans un miroir et quand je
me regarde je vois mon pire cauchemar je
vois un alcoolique
alors ok je suis alcoolique jeu malades
c'est quoi cette maladie
d'abord on n'est pas alcoolique parce
qu'on boit de l'alcool
on n'est pas le comique non plus parce
qu'on boit trop d'alcool
j'ai des amis qui boivent autant que moi
largement même plus que moi qui sont pas
alcooliques pour autant dans la
différence entre eux et moi c'est que
moi je ne bois pas par plaisir même pas
par envie
je bois par besoin un besoin
irrépressible
c'est un peu comme on a besoin d'air
pour respirer j'avais besoin d'alcool
pour vivre tout simplement pour
communiquer pour travailler quand
j'avais le moral ou quand j'avais pas le
moral quand j'apprenais une bonne
nouvelle quand j'apprenais une mauvaise
nouvelle j'avais besoin d'alcool
ma maladie c'est ça la dépendance
l'addiction et ça dépasse la raison
alors certains proches me disait regarde
toi tu es en train de te détruire gpat a
tous envie de me détruire moi je tenais
vraiment à la vie aucune intention de me
faire du mal non moi l'alcool c'était ce
qui me permettait de vivre c'est ce
qu'il me retenait à ma vie à la vie à ma
vie
c'était à la fois mon médicament est mon
présent il me sauver et en même temps il
me tuer c'est juste insupportable pour
les proches
alors parfois fojtik n'importe quoi par
amour
te laisse pas lille tous les palaces des
femmes
regarde ce que tu fais subir à tes
enfants si tu m'aimes tu dois changer
changer
il faudrait pour ça que je sois maître
de ma maladie je peux c'est là la
contrôler
mais l'alcoolisme n'est pas plus
contrôlable qu'un cancer est-ce qu'on va
demander 1 1 le scénic pour guérir de
changer j'ai appris aussi que si on peut
mourir alcoolique on peut mourir de
honte
l'alcoolique est un spécialiste de la
voix lui colle à la peau
cela va avec on se couche avec le temps
d'une cuite va mieux le temps d'une
clique
on boit pas honte et puis on a honte de
boire
et on boit encore effacé langues
l'impasse et pourtant pourtant me
reconnaître alcoolique m'a plutôt
soulagé oui oui on va me proposer des
solutions va me proposer un traitement
on va s'occuper de moi mais un
alcoolique n'est décidément pas un
malade comme les autres pour ses prêts
il est quand même un peu plus difficile
à plaindre
c'est vrai que c'est une maladie mais
enfin c'est quand même une maladie qu'il
s'inflige non et puis pour arrêter il
lui faut un peu de volonté
qu'ils le veuillent quoi
tu prends moi un bon infarctus
un cancer des os ça c'est de la maladie
on a les médicaments on a les
traitements on a les protocoles
on a les médecins dans les hôpitaux on a
tous on sait faire ça marche ou pas mais
on sait faire
l'alcoolisme et puis c'est vrai
plusieurs amis médecins me l'ont dit à
vous et d'une certaine manière
l'alcoolique
ce n'est vraiment pas un malade de
fréquentable non c'est vrai il est il
est tricheur truqueurs jouent pas le jeu
on sait pas vraiment s'il a envie de
guérir et puis et puis se plaint tout le
temps
malheureux dans les salles d'attentes
avec les autres patients ce n'est pas un
malade convenable
en fait ce qui est insupportable pour
les médecins et ça je les comprends
franchement c'est qu'ils sont
complètement démunis ils sont
impuissants
c'est une maladie chronique ok une
maladie donc incurable ok ils reçoivent
des malades qui vont mourir
pas facile alors on les adresse à des
confrères l'accueillant ou des
spécialistes qui vont les envoyer
quelques temps dans un centre de cure et
puis ils ressortent et puis c'est une
rechute
et puis ils repartent et puis ils
reviennent et plus heureux on ne sait où
il ya un grand grand malentendu entre
les médecins et les alcooliques
le premier que j'ai rencontré le premier
médecin spécialiste un alcoologue m'a
dit texto 1
vous avez vous avez finalement pour
arrêter de boire
il suffit juste d'arrêter de boire
merci docteur comme le vaudois il vers
six mois ont passé j'ai essayé beaucoup
de choses de thérapie diverses et
variées et rien ne marche
j'ai compris que c'était un peu de ma
faute
manque de volonté j'ai appris aussi
qu'il y avait peut-être en moi quelque
chose de deux mauvais
regardez robin williams ça fait
plusieurs années qu'il avait rendu
public son addiction à l'alcool sa
maladie son alcoolisme
vous avez donné la mort cet été alors il
n'est pas mort et puis c'est dans sa
lutte contre une maladie qu'il savait
incurable non il est mort emporté par
ses démons
alors n'y a pas de traitement n'y a pas
de médecins n'y a pas de médicaments
mais un peu d'exercice mon hiver 2008 un
livret publié il raconte une histoire
étonnante l'histoire de son auteur
olivier ameisen c'est un professeur en
cardiologie un français docteur donc
expatriés à new york il exerce dans un
très grand hôpital c'est un c'est un
médecin brillant un gérant gien brillant
un cardiologue plein d'avenir plein de
promesses il a un charisme fou il est
alcoolique
alors il a tout essayé pour s'en sortir
un des cures par dizaines des rendez
vous chez les alcooliques anonymes par
centaines
rien n'a marché
une rentre en transes et il s'intéresse
à ce moment là un médicament presque
oublier lé étudie de près il en modifie
la posologie il monte les doses ils le
test sur lui-même et après quelques
semaines il se dit guéri
gd alcool est guéri il ne ressent plus
besoin compulsif de boire bon le
médicament a brisé son addiction
il se décrit indifférent à l'alcool aux
indifférent l'alcool
c'est quoi ce médicament c'est un vieux
médicaments mis sur le marché dans les
années 70 pour soigner les spasmes
musculaires
il a fait ses preuves il ne présente
aucun danger
il est en vente libre dans certains pays
européens
on le trouve aujourd'hui sous forme
générique sous le nom de baclofène il ne
l'est remboursés par la sécurité sociale
il coûte presque rien 3,035 n'est pas
destiné à soigner l'alcoolisme à temps
mais dans les années 90 des des
chercheurs
on fait des essais assez curieux sur des
rats ils ont découvert une propriété
assez étonnante sur les addictions des
rats cocaïnomane et alcoolique traités
au baclofène
en quelques semaines les rats buvette
l'eau olivier ameisen s'est inspiré de
ses études pour mettre au point un
protocole un traitement
et ça marche sur l'homme en 2008 ils
sont quelques rares très rares médecins
en france à prescrire le baclofène jal
rives
j'arrive à contacter l'un d'entre eux
est un médecin très sérieux un chef de
service dans un grand hôpital parisien
il me reçoit il m'explique le le
médicament le traitement il me rédige
une ordonnance
alors là je suis pas très rassuré un non
j'ai pas peur du médicament
techniquement je sais que je ne risque
rien il me fera de toute façon beaucoup
moins de malte l'alcool
non ce que je ressens est un peu plus
inquiétant en fait je ressens la peur de
guérir oui c'est vrai quoi si jamais je
dis qu'est ce que je vais devenir moi
comment je vais faire sans alcool pour
me lever le matin pour aller bosser pour
dire bonjour à ma chérie pour aller voir
mes enfants et même pour aller me
coucher le soir quand je fait
concrètement je me faisais incapable de
faire ou de dire quoi que ce soit sans
alcool sans alcool comment je vais faire
la peur de guérir
c'est le monde à l'envers
mon amoureuse elle est là et puis c est
logique
elle ne m'a jamais lâché sais pas
comment elle avait tu pas certain
qu'elles mêmes d'ailleurs sache
exactement comment l ap mais elle est là
prête être prête à faire confiance à ce
médicament
à espérer quelque chose avec moi
moi j'avais à la fois peur de guérir
peur que ça marche pas on fait j'avais
tout j'en était elle si elle était prête
à jouer le jeu sans elle et sans cet
espoir partagé à deux je crois que je
n'aurais jamais commencer le traitement
23 janvier 2009 un mois et demi après
avoir avalé mon premier cachet début de
soirée l'heure de l'apéro j'ai un peu
d'avancé et c'est arrivé comme ça
subitement ce soir l'un pendant plus
d'une heure
j'ai oublié mon verre sur un meuble dans
l'appartement
oubliez un verre plein d'alcool je
regardais tout à coup les bouteilles les
verres remplis
cela ne me disait tout simplement plus
rien
j'ai pas réfléchi j'ai pas rester je
sais pas dire non aux fonds non tout
simplement je n'en avais plus envie
c'est une impression indescriptible j'ai
ressenti
physiquement ce qu'était cette fameuse
indifférence mon addiction n'a pas été
diminué
elle a été supprimée
aujourd'hui je suis libre et libre
libre de ne pas boire
ou de boire un verre ou de temps en
temps quand j'ai envie et plaisir
mais plus par 2 juin
depuis cinq ans je n'ai plus jamais été
ivres
sans effort
et je vous promets que ça ne manque pas
au fond je ne juge pas comme vous
monsieur n'appelle pas de problème avec
l'alcool
vous madame tenu comme vous moi enfin
comme vous et moi quoi
alors c'est un miracle dont ou par un
miracle c'est aussi miraculeux que le
fait que ben d'un cachet d'aspirine sur
un mal de tête du préfet d'une molécule
dans le cerveau est ce que c'est une
drogue qui remplace l'alcool alors au
sens où un médicament est une drogue oui
oui oui
sauf qu'il n'ya jamais eu de fortes
hausses par baclofène
et que ce médicament main juste guéri
sauvés alors que l'autre me tuer est-ce
que je prends encore du baclofène
oui petit dos presque superstition
les médecins disent que je suis guéri
son traitement guéri sous traitement un
peu comme les diabétiques avec insuline
thierry guerrier sous traitement ouais
moi sa jambe a
alors guéri oui mais maintenant c'est là
que le plus dur commence lucide je suis
lucide et à la fois c'est formidable
mais c'est aussi très très violent il
faut se remettre debout il faut
réapprendre à aller vers les autres il
faut réapprendre à communiquer accepter
le regard sceptique forcément des autres
la honte est encore là toujours la honte
de ce qu'on a été de ce qu'on a fait là
on du chaos qu'on a sommé pour soi même
et pour son entourage
je dois attendait une place parmi les
gens je suis libre oui mais libre pour
faire quoi et comment
personne n'attendait un médicament comme
celui ci personne alors il pose problème
aujourd'hui
il pose problème ça gêne ça dérange les
intérêts politiques et financiers les
experts les lobbys puis le poids des
habitudes des corporatismes 120 morts
par jour des milliers de familles
dévastées
un médicament qui sauve des vies et ça
dérange
ça dérange qui
pourquoi est-ce que franchement j'ai la
tête d'un illuminé non parce qu'on m'a
dit ça ou si on m'a dit non non stéphane
non non tu as l'impression d'être guéri
mais en fait n'est pas guéri non c'est
juste une illusion tu vois pas ce que
c'est juste pas possible donc tu as
certainement l'impression en c'est
bizarre mais faut pas rêver non non tu
n'es pas guéri tu ne te rends pas compte
certains d'entre vous pensent la même
chose j'aime bien mauvaise nouvelle pour
vous
nous sommes de plus en plus nombreux à
ne pas nous rendre compte que nous
sommes guéris
environ cent mille personnes sont
aujourd'hui guérie deux de leurs
maladies de l'alcoolisme sous baclofène
les ventes de baclofène ont été
multipliées par 50 depuis 2008 50
et le nombre de médecins de médecins
éclairé curieux
qui s'informent et se forment et
prescrivent correctement ce médicament
augmente sans cesse
ils sont aujourd'hui entre sept et dix
mille en france certains disent pas
et pourtant pourtant on entend encore
ici ou là vous est alors le baclofène où
il va manger entendre du poète
oui alors il paraît que ça marche pas
non bah non c'est moi j'ai lu des trucs
j'ai entendu des gens tu sais il paraît
que ça marche pas du tout non puis alors
on fait tout à fait pas rêver hein faut
pas rêver non je serai pas moi
des gens meurent l'alcool plus et
toujours pas l'ignorance bon j'ai quand
même une excellente nouvelle pour doute
ce soir contre cette saloperie de
maladie on vit un moment décisif le
médicament on l'a le protocole médical
avant pendant après le traitement
c'est pas encore ça mais ça va de mieux
en mieux il reste l'entourage les
projets et le regard différent que vous
porterez sur cette maladie sur ces
malades
et sur le médicament cette petite dose
de curiosité de confiance indispensable
à la réussite du traitement
informez vous poser des questions ne
vous contentez pas de réponse toute
faite qu'on fait un peu trop rapidement
ce médicament sauve des vies nous avons
les clés vous avez les clés alors
qu'elle peut maintenant qu'est ce qu'on
risque guérir merci